uh so liz truster's first call was with
president zielinski of ukraine you've
obviously done work with particularly
women in ukraine as well and what are
you expecting to see from the new prime
minister in terms of that all-important
policy so i think we're going to see a
lot of focus on this kind of narrative
about threats
and i think ukraine and russia alongside
obviously china where she's keen to show
that she's going to take a strong stance
we're going to see a lot of that i don't
think we're going to see any reduction
support for ukraine i don't think we're
going to see any change but i would love
to see as you know she's announced this
reconstruction conference she wants to
do in 2023 that's the right plan we
should always be talking about
reconstruction and where we go forward
um but i think what we really need to
see is a fleshing out of what does putin
must lose mean because for months now we
heard boris say it we had liz say it and
i think we'll continue to hear her say
it but what does that actually mean what
does that look like uh how much
authority and autonomy are going to give
to the ukrainians to decide what putin
has lost looks like um so i think
there's a lot of fleshing out of that
question that needs to be done it feels
to me like we're moving into a new stage
of the war almost um
it feels unlikely that you know suddenly
putin's going to take keeve it also
feels unlikely that he's suddenly just
going to withdraw it's almost like we're
in a cold war he he's using new tactics
like cutting off gas supply how do we
react to that
so i think there's that really
murky bit of a war we get that real war
of attrition as we go into winter
everything will freeze um i have you
know two ukrainian families living with
me their hope is that everything they
will have success by the time we get to
winter because they know that everything
freezes then and that moment of freezing
winter will be a really interesting
reset because we will need to look
around the world at how much support we
have and it's a real vulnerability point
so i think one of the things i've been
talking about is these abstentionist
countries who haven't taken a view and
haven't taken aside
as we go into winter when everything
freezes are countries who are currently
our allies are you talking about oh so
if there's countries like india for
example uh there are countries a lot of
the commonwealth
uh
countries
in latin america and so on and so on a
lot of them haven't won state positions
same in the indo-pacific
we already have them with their
positions but as we go into winter we
could see people who are currently with
us but going away and we need to make
sure we keep that support we maintain
that spawn that's gonna be a real
challenge how much pressure do you put
on a country like india i mean we're
trying to
sign a trade deal with them as well
aren't we yeah i think that's an
enormous challenge i think the global
south
this is what i think so liz likes to
talk about her a network of liberty that
again is something we need to flesh out
what does that mean what does it look
like is it operationalizing the
commonwealth uh is it about looking at
these abstentions countries she needs to
look at how we bring these people into
fold and how we make them work but
these countries don't want to be made to
pick and we have to be very careful it's
the same question that comes to china
you cannot force these countries to pick
and actually their priority is uh in the
pacific for example it's about surviving
climate change in the countries and
global south it's about the famine
that's coming in the food shortages
we can't just tell them they must pick a
side because we have particularly we're
not necessarily backing that up with the
support to allow them to make that
choice um so it's a very sensitive
diplomacy and that's going to be the
most biggest challenge i think for this
government is the nuance of diplomacy
you can't have black and white
relationships you can't compartmentalize
things when they're unhelpful you have
to have that complicated discussion
that's sometimes quite tough how do you
think this trust will approach that well
i think liz has shown that she's willing
to be a disrupter and she's achieved
some things as a result of doing that
and but she's also shown herself to be
someone who's listened so i went to her
last september and said i was really
worried about the balkans in particular
bosnia had a list of 13 things i would
like to see her deliver she'd live a 10
of 13 and the uk entire policy towards
balkans and bosnia changed overnight
we've been leading on the world stage on
it so i think when she can see there's a
urgent need she acts and she makes
difference and she did that by bringing
people together but i also recognize
that sometimes uh
playing to the crowd can lead to quite a
dangerous position in diplomacy there
are always cameras lights and action and
that can lead itself to those quick
quips that are actually quite dangerous
in the long run interesting you're
thinking about like macron for example
yeah and i think i think that was a not
a very sensible move i don't think
anyone would disagree with that uh if
she gave the answer on china you could
understand why again you wouldn't want
to tie yourself either way but france is
a major ally we work with them very
closely we've just come through the
orchestra relationship difficulties um
and orcas was absolutely the right
decision that's gonna that is in the
long term one and being one of our key
defenses
are you worried that it and we're
talking here i just realized probably
explained you know we're talking here
when she wasn't
she refused to say whether or not
president macron was an ally could that
damage our relationship do you think so
i think it obviously is so important the
relationship between two world leaders
but actually we see this so much in the
media where oh if this person this
person don't become best friends there
can't be a positive relationship between
those countries but the frameworks and
the civil service and diplomatic
relations those are actually the
fundamentals and they're not at risk in
any way i've got to ask you are you
going to run for the now vacant position
as chair of the foreign affairs select
committee so i've i'm really grateful um
i've had a lot of positive conversations
uh with colleagues um over the last i
guess 12 hours however long today yes
i've lost track of the day so i'm
seriously considering it and i think you
know we need someone who understands
these challenges knows what's under the
bonnet and how the engine of the foreign
office works and i'm really touched by
how many people have reached out so
i'm definitely considering it sounds
like a yes
look it's my passion and i think i can
bring that experience of
working countering hostile states
counter-terrorism and as i said
understand the foreign office and i
think hopefully colleagues have seen
that i'll work with them interesting
stuff alyssa keynes thank you very much
indeed for coming on the program tonight